Let's go back to a demonstration here, and
I am going to show you an app called crashy.
It does exactly that really well. Matt, why
don't you start the app, and it crashed.
Note there's a button there called Report.
The user can press Report, can provide a description
of what happened. They can look at all the
data they are going to send, make sure they
are comfortable with that data and they can
hit send. And that is sent back to the developer.
Note on this screen the Android Marketplace,
note a brand-new tab, "Bugs." And when you
click on bugs we will show you those reports
for your application, and we will show you
the entire stack trace of what happened.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: We thought you might like
that. And closing the loop, allowing apps
to get better and better.
All right. Let's go back to slides.
I want to go a little bit beyond Froyo and
show you a sneak peek at other exciting things
that we are doing in the Android Marketplace.
I think you are going to like some of these
things. Let's go back to demo.
Matt is now showing you the Android Marketplace,
except this is unlike anything you have ever
seen before. It's the Android Marketplace
accessible from a browser on a PC, and that's
great.
Matt can browse apps, he can look at reviews,
but you will look up in the upper right-hand
corner, Matt is signed in, and because he
is signed in, we know every Android device
that he has.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Yeah, he is a little weird.
In this case, the device that he has on the
stage, he has selected at nutter butter, nutty
buddy, something. Like I said, he is weird.
He has got his phone selected, and so now
he can go browse a particular app. He is going
to find an app he likes like Open Table. Hold
on, hold on Matt. He is going to hit free
and he is going to go and download the app.
What do you think happens? Let's see, what
happens today on some other systems. You find
the app, you download it to your PC or Mac.
You then have to tether your device. Once
it's on your PC, you have to then convert
it over that tethering to your device and
then make that sync happen. Well, guess what?
We discovered something really cool. It's
called the Internet.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: And when Matt presses download,
keep your eye on the Android device.
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Over the air.
Isn't that totally great? Over the air, installed
on your device.
Now, it turns out it's called the Android
-- or the Marketplace because it's more than
apps. In fact, what we are about to show you
is a new category.
How about some music?
Matt, why don't you find an album or song
you like, and why don't you just send it to
the device using the Internet, over the air.
And boom, keep your eye on the Android device.
There you go. There is the music coming right
on down.
[ Cheering and Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Now, we're not done yet. Some
of you may be thinking this is really cool,
this is so hot, but I have my music already
on my device at home, my Windows media or
my iTunes library. I have thousands of songs
there. What do I do with those?
We recently acquired a company called Simplified
Media and it is our intention to incorporate
that technology into the marketplace as well
and that allows you at home to run a simple
piece of hardware that makes all your non-DRM
music available to your Android device. Would
you like to see this? Let's go to your Android
device.
Android device has two songs on it. That's
nice, but I want more than two songs. I want
all my music I have.
So Matt will go down and select -- I guess
he has to plug in the device so you can hear
it.
>>> Options, touch nine. Thank you for calling
the fifth floor restaurant.
>>Vic Gundotra: My God!
[ Applause ]
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Let me offer a public apology.
Now.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: You know what's really odd?
Is that they didn't pick up all that time.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Wow!
Getting back to music. Two songs. I want all
my music. He is going to select that button
that says all, and magically, all the music
is now available.
Now, you might be wondering what just happened?
We are making your whole music library available
to your Android device as a stream. So, for
example, if Matt was to select a particular
song, I guess Matt's an Earth, Wind and Fire
fan, hit play. Will this work?
(music playing).
[ Applause ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Yeah, we think users are going
to love this feature.
All right. Let's go back to slides.
Let's talk a little bit about advertising.
It turns out that we know a little bit about
advertising. Today happens or this year happens
to be Google's tenth anniversary of providing
advertising solutions. And we have learned
a few things in that decade.
One of the foremost things we have learned
is if you want to have a healthy ecosystem
of advertising, you need advertisers. And
we have hundreds of thousands of them.
That means if you have an ad spot, we have
a relevant ad that can fill it. It's called
inventory.
We're not new at this game. We're not working
with a handful of partners and charging them
a million dollars each to be a part of our
program.
Okay? So we can be your advertising partner.
We have also learned something else in that
decade. That advertisers and accomplishers
have different kinds of needs.
There are local advertisers, there's direct
response advertisers, there are brand advertisers.
And if you want to play, you need formats
that meet the needs of those kinds of advertisers.
And we have those formats.
A third thing that we have learned, advertising
needs to be measured. And that means it needs
to have great tools.
Why does it need to be measured? Well, you
need to know if the money you are spending
is giving you a return on the investment.
You need to know which campaigns are working
so you can invest more in them or tweak them
as necessary.
And it turns out that we have some tools you
might have heard of called DoubleClick, analytics,
AdSense, AdWords? The tools the industry knows
and loves are being used seamlessly to work
in the mobile environment.
And finally, we know it's important to be
open to innovation.
Now, I don't even know what the ponies have
to do with this slide, but part of being open
is when you get a designer who gives you a
slide, you go with it.
[ Laughter ]
>>Vic Gundotra: Let's show you each one of
these four points and go to demos.
Now, these are real advertisers and real applications.
Let me make that point clear. You are looking
at Backgrounds. One of the most popular applications
available in the Android Marketplace.
At the top, you are looking at a Google ad.
Our ad program, which has been available only
to a limited number of beta participants,
is called AdSense for Mobile Apps, AFMA, and
you are looking at one of those AFMA ads.
You are looking at our large inventory of
text ads being optimized and served on that
device. We are taking advantage of the small
space we have and you are seeing the nice
rotation. That's just one ad format. What
happens if Matt selects something like beaches?
Then we can serve a contextually relevant
ad. In this case, Kayak is a popular Web site,
an application for travel. But in this case
when you click on the ad, we take you to deep
within the Android Marketplace so the user
can download the app. That's another important
ad format.
Let's show you another format.
This is a third format for brand advertising.
In other words, a banner ad where an advertiser
has decided to convey their message through
an image. We support that.
How about another category, and this is something
that we are announcing available today, and
that's an expandable ad format.
One of the things that we have seen through
our research is that users, if at all possible,
would like to stay within the context of the
application they are using.
So in this case, when Matt selects that Volkswagen
ad, it expands right out, you can look at
that ad and when he is done with it he can
simply make it slide right back in.
We think that's great for advertisers, and
we think that's great for users.
That expandable format is available today.
Let me show you another brand-new one we are
making available today. This is an expandable
ad format. This is a Flixter application.
Why don't you expand that ad out. In this
case it's not just display; it's rich media.
He is linking directly to a trailer. He clicked
on it and the trailer will begin